[Inaudible].
Every night, every night, every night I five shows last night.
I had three tonight. Oh my God. Are you from New York? New Orleans,
born and raised. So you moved down here then? Oh yeah. I moved out here.
I did count for eight months. I was like, this is it.
I finally found what I want to do. I don't care how hard it is.
I'm going to make it work. And that was it. Right?
So that's the hustle moved to New York, uh, with 800 bucks in my pocket,
I got mugged three times in a year. My landlord died of AIDS.
And the first day I was here, I had a pigeon in my apartment.
I worked in this building as a janitor for two years. I had a lot of fun.
You smell like garbage and donkey.
How are you sniff this? Ooh, that's her. See you later, Janet.
I believe that guy can't believe you up.
Does anyone else sometimes feel like they're getting paid to be sick?
I quit the day job and uh, 2011 best day of my life. I was a janitor.
Really? Yeah.
My floor is from nine to five and I would do open mics at night and shows a
night. And eventually, you know, after a while I just saved up a ton of money.
I was super poor. I saved everything.
I had got a TV spot on comedy central quitting the job the next
day, I got quite a route schedule for tonight. Uh, yeah,
not in New York that much. So when I'm here, I really cherish the time.
I'm only here on like Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday,
you leave Thursday to do weekends on the road,
going to Philly this weekend and Montreal, it's going to be a good year.
I've never heard a woman say this conversation irrelevant.
Ooh, Jesus, 17 minutes. I felt like an hour and a half.
I'm going to follow that. Oh man, you could do it.
[inaudible] it looked like a, keep a box cutter on you. So don't hurt me.
Appreciate the boom.
[inaudible] Oh, really? So you look at my
[inaudible] guy, right? Like the money
I have no money. We would not get along.
[inaudible].
It's sad that like comics are like drug addicts where you need those extremes
just to feel good. You know? Like you need that, that, that hit.
You need that fix. I mean, I buy a new iPad or I get,
I get a BJ after a show. Like that's all in fun and games, but it's not enough.
You need that, that rush. That, that crowd, you need everything.
How sad is that? That it to be happy. I need all,
all those factors have to happen in a comedy club and audience has to show up.
Somebody has to, I want a comedy clubs. I'm used to by a microphone, by a light.
Somebody has to allow you to perform there and you have to do well,
all those things have to go on just for us to be happy. And if we get heckled,
it's all ruined. We're selfish, terrible, um,
misunderstood people. Well, we're going to go beat up a bunch of cops.
You should come with, you know,
the feeling of taking a cop's gun and turning it on him. It's a great feeling.
How do you feel about the Jews? Which what's that mean?
What does that word mean? That's what this protest is about. Right?
All right. Well, what do you, what do you look for in a man.
Really? Is that what's going on? I have a boyfriend.
Do you? I'm I'm protesting against that.
Welcome back to a new day in Cleveland. It is time for a little bit.
Beautiful.
So welcome here into the engine. The studio. It's good to have you here.
It's a, it's a pleasure. I'm a little hung over a little gay, but uh,
just glad to be here with you sister.
Oh, I appreciate you saying that.
I'm very happy to be here with you to my erection. Okay.
But uh, been farting it up in the green room.
Is that a guy thing you would hear?
No woman would ever say something like that.
No more. Maybe a quirky thing. Oh my gosh.
Claimed TV. I mean, you know, you live,
you live in New York city now, but you're from new Orleans.
Yeah. Wow. Well done. You're running a grinder by him.
I was looking you up. Yes.
Hey, that's why I'm a comedian because I got to get love somewhere. Sorry.
Is that a me too? All right.
I can handle it. So, but we're big. I mean, you're young.
So getting into this business and getting into this business
and um.
35, 35, not that young, but uh, you know, not on the Viagra yet.
Or am I, who knows comedians?
We're our own breed. We're a weird group. You know, we're like, uh, we're weird.
We're inappropriate, we're awkward. And we're offensive.
Like we have comics really have no nerve endings when it comes to swastika,
swastikas, abortions, AIDS, and STDs talk. But, uh,
I only hang out with comics really, which is probably unhealthy. But, uh,
that's the only people I feel like I can relate to and get along with.
That's why comedy is great. It's it's like, you're saying, Hey,
I've got these fun ideas. I think you'll enjoy it,
but don't interrupt me and don't ask anything of me I'll hit.
This is what I can give you. Comics were terrible. Socially.
Usually not good with around other people, but we still have something to say,
we still have some talent to give. So we need to just let us give it out.
You watch and then we'll leave. We can interact interacting. I'm not good at,
but I still have something to offer verbally.
I think a day job for a comedian is much harder because we're wired differently.
So it's more, it takes more mental energy to be normal.
Like you mortals, you know, it's tough. Not you,
but everybody eating at this restaurant.
If I had a meaningful conversation with them,
I think a lot of them would walk away just like that. Guy's wacky.
That guy has got some issues. He's a little dark. Maybe I am done.
And don't worry. I'm not cheating here. These just as I've drawn, here you go.
Where do we begin? I man, we've got to address the elephant and the anal Corona.
It's a bits of. We all, we're all sick of it. That's why we're here. You know,
Karen has been so long. It feels like the check engine light, you know,
at first you're scared of it. Then after a while, you're like, it.
I gotta go to work. Any Jews here. Hey, go.
[Inaudible].
Either. There are no Jews here. Or Jews are like,
I'm not falling for that one again.
I wasn't getting a hand job at the moment in the car. Oh, that guy. All right.
Well done, sir. I didn't know. The hand job was still around Dominick.
I liked the cars that you can't tell who hates me. Ah. That car back down.
If you really care about it and are passionate and go for it and want it,
I think you'll get there. So the other thing that would work,
how much luck is involved in this process,
look has a punch for sure luck does,
but you can't control that and you can't worry about it.
You just got to focus on you writing and working and busting your.
You gotta make your own luck in a way, the hustle and man,
just going to work every day, uh, you know, beat tired.
I'm eyes were red. I'd go to bed at like four or 5:00 AM. I'd wake up at eight,
go to work and then go do shows, write new material,
get that clean five minutes, boom, audition, hear bang, bang, bang,
TV spot.
I got, I just put a special out to all my materials gone.
It'd be one thing that I could come back on stage is jumping in my old act,
but I just put out an act. I put out on YouTube. It's all out there.
So now I got no material and no skills. Hopefully there's a crowd tonight.
And uh, yeah, we'll, we'll yuck it up and really offend somebody.
But it's sold out. Is it sold out? I didn't know that.
Oh my God.
So that was fun. I got a lot of work done, tried some new jokes, boy,
it was great. Uh, just a tough time.
New special came out and I'm rusty and I'm doing new material.
So I'm all over the road. But, uh, that was great. Crowds were great.
I loved Texas and now I gotta fly back to New York.
So when I hit the bar and drank with the staff and the local comics.
[Inaudible].